when I think about the opioid crisis I
think what we're really talking about
our deaths due to opioid overdose and so
an overdose can occur really anytime
anyone uses an opioid and and when I say
opioid that's really an umbrella term
that includes things like painkillers
prescription painkillers so vicodin
percocet oxycodone all the way to heroin
and actually with the opium poppy which
is where originally these substances
were derived from so that's sort of the
big term and what we've seen in
Massachusetts and across the country has
been this dramatic rise and
unintentional death from overdose on
these drugs or medications and well
again this can happen anytime someone
uses an opioid most often when we see
these deaths it's due to untreated
opioid addiction so often we're really
talking about right now is a crisis of
opioid addiction and one of the reasons
that's so devastating and all of these
deaths are so devastating is that opioid
addiction is a completely treatable
illness and so really no one should be
dying from an overdose because we have
things we can do in the setting of an
overdose to save someone's life and to
keep people safe while they're actually
in the throes of addiction and we have
treatment that we know reduces the death
toll and helps people get into long-term
remission to lead meaningful lives that
really shouldn't be foreshortened by
this disease every day I encounter
people in recovery who inspire me and
who really give me hope around this you
know I think a lot of what we hear about
you know in the media is the you know
people who aren't doing well you know
people who are you know tragically dying
most of the people that that I have the
privilege to work with are are really
making great strides in their lives it's
an inspiring thing to watch and I feel
privileged to be a part of that
and it gives me it really gives me great
hope for the future the opioid crisis
began about 15 years ago when we saw an
increase in the prescription of opioid
analgesics or narcotic analgesics or
sometimes referred to as pain relievers
because we saw such an explosion of
prescriptions what we found was that
more people than ever before were
exposed to opioids in past generations
not very many people who are exposed to
opioids but with this surge in
prescribing with a genuine intention of
relieving pain those who have
vulnerability to becoming dependent on
opioids are developing an addiction
problem on opioids we're now exposed
with the prescription opioid pain
medication it seemed like there was an
abundance of these drugs everywhere you
know I had a lot of friends that also
had injuries that would be in prescribed
medication it just seemed like it was
easier for my generation as an underage
person to get access to a legal
prescription narcotics on the streets
and they get somebody to buy you alcohol
because of the accessibility of these
drugs the problem that we have currently
is that practitioners are literally all
over the map some people will not
prescribe anything at any for any
condition and some people will give 30
60 90 pills of of oxycodone or
hydrocodone and so I think what's
happening is that we're creating this
severe problem of expectations for
patients because they don't know what
they're going to get from which doctor
we need to do a better job with that I
pretty much started using drugs actually
I started drinking alcohol before the
age of 14 and then eventually from there
I progressed into snorting cocaine and
it was probably around the age of maybe
20 that I started snorting heroin the
opioid crisis is twofold actually it's
prescription medication and also powder
heroin and now the introduction of fact
No
in various forms of that so it's taken
on two folds where we have to attack it
from both ends
no period crisis it's affecting
everybody and it's in every community it
doesn't discriminate against anybody
doesn't matter poverty doesn't matter
race doesn't matter where you come from
every family is affected by it
[Music]
you